c'est le scandale christian quesada hier
nous avons après christian quesada le
plus grand champion des 12 coups de midi
a été mise en examen pour détention et
diffusion d'imagés pédo pornographiques
et corruption de mineurs il a été passé
en détention provisoire
une enquête est ouverte on va vous
expliquer tout ça et on vous répondra à
toutes les questions que vous vous posez
là dessus seraient remerciés loup
d'avoir été avec nous parce que je
voudrais pas qu'elle reste pour
l'assureur
sur cette séquence où dansaient sur tes
mots merci regardez
[Applaudissements]
lapeyre christian quesada a éclaté hier
celle d'un champion de jeu télé au
parcours incroyable pour qui mercredi la
vie s'est arrêtée et inculpée et écrouée
pour détention d'imagés
pédopornographiques christan quesada le
grand champion du jeu les 12 coups de
midi 2 vient d'être mise en examen
il est accusé de détention et de
diffusion de centaines d'imagés
pédopornographiques c'est entre 2016 et
2017 que les téléspectateurs de tf1 ont
pu découvrir christian quesada en tant
que candidat imbattable des 12 coups de
midi au cours de 193 victoires
successives le joueur empochera plus de
800000 euros dont une partie en cadeau
et deviendra un temps le plus grand
champion de l'histoire des jeux télé en
france mais hier la belle histoire a
pris fin l'homme de 54 ans a été arrêtée
et mise en examen pour détention de
centaines de photos et vidéos de mineurs
subissant des viols et diverses
agressions sexuelles des images
découvertes sur son ordinateur mais
alors pourquoi était-il dans le viseur
de la justice depuis un an
tout ça grâce à la manifestation d'une
jeune fille qui avait porté plainte
contre un internaute qui se faisait
passer en ligne pour une jeune
adolescente mineure dont le but
d'obtenir des photos dénudées d'autres
jeunes filles derrière ce conte
christian quesada à l'heure actuelle
l'homme qui s'était connaître par ses
bonnes réponses à la télévision est
toujours en détention les enquêteurs
cherchent à savoir s'il appartient ou
non un réseau d'échangés d'imagés pédo
pornographiques
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que c'est la sphère
dont tout le monde parle actuellement et
ce qui est dingue c'est depuis
l'annnonce de la sphère les réseaux
sociaux bien sûr de son nez ses réseaux
sociaux de question qu'ils allaient sont
épluchés et plusieurs tweets
rejaillissent on avait vu le 19 mars
dernier christian quesada ironisé sur un
article du parisien on déconne évoquant
michel fourniret un violeur pédophile et
tueur en série et les kids united il
disait un peu comme si fournir est allé
au concert des kids united voilà parce
que c'était voilà la présence de
l'islamophobe l'islamologue tariq
ramadan mise en examen pour viol c'était
un tweet du parisien il avait répondu ça
et c'est vrai que on avait vu voilà
christian kessal a aussi commenté des
photos de jeunes filles mineures sur
twitter fait vraiment joli ma belle
bisous alors ça va là on épluche tout
gilles verdez que vous avez des infos là
dessus c'est que vous êtes nombreux à en
avoir
alors alors ce qui est très surprenant
c'est que rien n'avait filtré
pourtant on a appris donc christian
quesada avait déjà été condamné à deux
ans de prison avec sursis notamment pour
détention d'image on avant de faire les
douze coups de m
rêvant de le faire donc c'est anglais
j'étais dans les années 2000 2000 voilà
exactement et s'est passé comme ça il
faut savoir que dans les émissions de
tf1
on ne demande pas des extraits de casier
judiciaire ça paraît très surprenant
aujourd'hui mais j'ai eu un des grands
maîtres de midi
on ne demande rien donc c'est passé
comme ça et christian kesavan avait pas
éveiller les soupçons
néanmoins il était totalement à part
dans le monde des grands maîtres les
maîtres de midi ceux qui ont gagné
beaucoup d'argent sont réunis sur une
messagerie whatsapp ils se connaissent
entre lui et a pas très secret il
détestait parler de sa vie privée
c'est quelqu'un que les gens proches de
lui qualifié de bizarre et aujourd'hui
tout ça ressort mais très honnêtement de
la part de tf1 de la production et des
anciens gagnants il n'y avait pas eu de
soupçons
alors on va revenir sauf si vous avez
plein d'infos déjà et il est apparu pour
la première fois la télévision dans
l'émission des chiffres et des lettres
c'était dans les années 80
regardez j'ai l'impression chers amis
que monsieur quesada va comme nous le
disons souvent en faire souffrir
quelques-uns
vous plaît très entraînés en plus c'est
le top de chazal il en est sorti
plusieurs monsieur que cela que je suis
sorti surtout avant d'être sorti non
mais ils ont qu' il y en a qui ont gardé
des séquelles quand même temps c'est
vrai ah oui il faudra de raconter ça
joue alors alors donc il est arrivé aux
chipsets est le seul joueur à avoir
remporté les trois épreuves télévisée la
coupe des champions 87 les master's en
89 et la coupe des clubs en 81
rencontres c'était un énorme champion
des chiffres et des athées puis il est
devenu une véritable star grâce aux
douze coups de midi sur tf1 sa première
participation
c'était le 4 juillet 2016 regarde pas le
permis de conduire il est aguerri sur
deux autres villes et un papa au foyer
de deux enfants féru de closets d'avoir
à l'aréna j à 42 ans élevé loi 43 ans il
est prêt à mouiller le maillot
y'a papa au foyer célibataire bonjour
christian aujourd'hui
alors c'est sa première participation
ici christian kassala est allé aux 12
coups de midi
c'est grâce à sa mère à l'époque il
n'avait pas un sou en poche regarder il
avait expliqué ça chez thierry ardisson
votre maman vous parle des 12 coups de
midi
tout avait elle a adoré votre mea cette
émission c'est est ce qu'on appelle une
vraie fan et c'était à la mort de votre
maman que vous décidez de vous inscrire
vous dites pour lui rendre hommage
tout à fait je pensais pas que j'allais
forcément refaire des jeux télé un jour
pour monter à paris vous êtes obligés
d'emprunter 19 euros pour payer
l'autocar c'est vrai j'ai voulu prendre
le moins cher et même ça j'avais pas
assez pour la alors après c'est vrai
tout le monde lundi parce que c'est un
des plus grands gagnants des jeux
télévision il ya même sept habite qui
lui consacre un portrait regardez il
raconte à l'époque dense et habite ce
que sa mère lui a dit sur son lit de
mort pour l'encourager à s'inscrire aux
12 coups de midi et regarde maintenant
sur son lit de mort vous dis mais il
faut que tu retournes jouer me dit vas-y
mon fils mais vas-y les douze coups
c'est fait pour toi toi tu connais tous
qu'un vrai dictionnaire ambulante une
encyclopédie
voilà comment nous parler ma maman et
j'allais faire combien d'émissions
je vais rester au quotidien pendant 193
émission ser 6 mois et demi alors tous
les midis près de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs ont suivi son parcours
dans le jeu si il caracolait en tête des
audiences un jour luc reichmann n'a
jamais fait une aussi grosse audience
même carré de christian pas ce qu'on
attendait de voir le champion tomber
vous a préparé une compile de christian
quesada c'était dans les 12 coups de
midi bien sûr il avait gagné plus de
800000 belambra agresseurs ils picorent
un petit peu ont toutes les informations
au fil du temps c'est une espèce de
papier buvard de la connaissance
quelle ville biblique marcel proust at
il donné pour titre à l'un des volets de
à la recherche du temps perdu
c'est ce dôme et gomorrhe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quel ordre religieux et militaire
jacques de molay at il été le grand
maître des templiers en 1988
quel cinéaste réalise le temps des
gitans kusturica le prénom de kusturica
émir z
oui emir kusturica bah oui bien sûr
alors ensuite l'émission a complètement
changé ça dit ce qu'il a gagné beaucoup
beaucoup de sauts ils étaient venus lui
raconter ici et en quelques mois il a
même réussi à trouver l'amour regarde un
petit peu à l'affût de pas mal de scoop
pas mal de dos je dis pas ça alors avec
du monde j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
quelqu'un durement parcours tv donc tout
va bien de ce côté là croyez-moi je suis
très comblé vont vivre un petit indice
la personne
qui vous aide il fait battre bon coeur
we are ainsi dans son traîneau mais ça
reste secret ça restera secret tout le
temps et mais ça se passe très bien des
trésors
alors ensuite il a été éliminé de
l'émission se rappelle tous de son
élimination et il avait fait un discours
émouvant lors de sa dernière regarde je
pense qu'il me faudra du temps déjà pour
trouver la simple formulation du merci
alors c'est vrai que ce
le premier merci ce sera pour vous il ya
eu vraiment très profond et très sincère
c'est très gentil
ensuite un merci à toutes les personnes
qui me soutiennent tous mes enfants
mon ex femme ma chérie
mes proches mes frères ma famille à
merci à toutes ces personnes qui ont
compris d'où je venais qui ont compris
comment je joue et qui ont compris à que
c'était un défi pour moi que je les
relever toutes ces personnes qui savent
que mon aventure elle a changé ma vie
que vous soyez le plus heureux possible
dans votre vie grâce aux touches odeurs
alors donc christian quesada avait un
énorme capital sympathie
je vais vous dire la vérité je vous fais
un aveu même moi j'ai pensé à christian
quesada un moment pour faire un jeu
autour de lui qui est plus fort que
christian quesada c'était voilà un
moment on avait réfléchi avec lui voilà
à faire du foot c'est vrai que voilà il
est on avait fait un ou deux rendez vous
avec lui tout le monde se l'arraché et
c'est vrai que c'était devenu une
véritable star des médias
regardez il faisait toutes les émissions
une vraie belle personne et j'ai parlé à
coeur où elle regardait sur dans le
cadre d'un jeu comme ça récurrent au
long nez au quotidien il faut avoir
quatre grandes qualités les
connaissances bien évidemment la mémoire
bien évidemment la rapidité est aussi
l'endurance vous n'avez jamais été un
enfant comme les autres
outre le fait que vous portiez des
couettes très tôt voit les photos c'est
vrai vous avez appris le dictionnaire
oui parker
alors c'est vrai qu'il était invité
partout où on adoré même un biopic en
préparation exactement un film sur lui
était en préparation et face à thierry
demaizière dans sept à huit à l'époque
il avait aussi montré une petite part
d'ombré puisque dans le passé il a avoué
être tombé dans la drogue et l'alcool
regarde je me rendais compte que
quelqu'un avait réussi à mettre dans un
livre tous les maux qui écrivait tous
les livres ils trouvaient ça absolument
fabuleux et vous allez apprendre par
coeur tous ces mots jusqu'à en plein
dans n y en a 10 je ne sais rien faire
d'autre que de jouer et vous dites dans
votre livre même jouer au con oui et là
dessus je suis pas le dernier
tiers-temps jeu sauf que là aussi c'est
excessif là aussi le jour où découvrez
l'alcool la cocaïne web beaucoup d'excès
beaucoup d'excès voilà dans le fait de
brûler l'argent par tous les bouts c'est
à dire que je suis quelqu'un qui aime
croquer tous qui a l'a apporté de soi et
après donc il a vu sa vie son jeu
changeait faut savoir qu'il est au rsa
et cela vous donne l'info que j'ai moi
également
c'est que la production endemol chercher
à ce moment là une personne vraiment en
difficulté ils sont dix ça serait énorme
d'avoir un très très grand champion
comme ça qui est en très grosse
difficultés financières est ce que vous
confirmez ça oui oui vous qui avez déjà
j'aimerais faire un souhait de la
production est pas aussi de jean luc
reichmann
après c'est vrai qu'ils font pas dans
quel sur la question joli je vais juste
excellent tennisman
mais l'histoire après pour le reste je
pense sincèrement que quand il passe six
mois tous les jours la télé ça
m'étonnerait que personne n'ait pris son
téléphone pour informer de son passé
parce que pour le coup c'était un vrai
passé judiciaire et ça m'étonne beaucoup
voilà c'est passé en train de préparer
le prouver ce alors s'adresse à plus de
huit cent mille euros de gains christian
a vu sa vie complètement changé il
explique ce qu'il a fait des cadeaux et
de l'argent qu'il a touché dans les 12
coups de midi et après vous allez me
dire ce qu'ils risquent
ce qui va se passer pour lui on parlera
de la réaction de jean-luc reichmann et
regardons tout en cumulé argent et
cadaujac et 1800 9392 euros je suis très
belle somme
les cadeaux sont absolument une caverne
d'ali baba vous ne savez pas trop quoi
faire parce que n'est pas permis de
conduire et vous avez vu combien de
voitures
j'ai eu cette voiture juste cette télé
des ordinateurs
des portables j'ai eu les appareils à
massat j'ai eu des boîtes pour chauffer
eu des boîtes à thé j'ai eu des tchèques
heures j'ai eu des guitares des les
maquettes de bateaux mais des trucs
vraiment de qualité dont je me sais que
faire la même voiture par exemple vous
avez rendu oui voiture aujourd'hui
offertes ulla à mon ex-femme
j'en ai gardé une pour le jour où je
passerai le permis ci passe par mir
jours alors il nous a raconté tout ça
aujourd'hui donc christian quesada comme
je voulais dit il a été interpellé jean
luc reichmann a bien sûr réagi sur les
réseaux sociaux ce matin suite à la
nouvelle dévastatrice que l'on a tous
découvert hier concernant christian
quesada je suis ce matin sous le choc je
ne peux qu'exprimer mon sentiment
d'horreur de dégoût et de colère
je réitère aujourd'hui tout mon respect
à la brigade des mineurs qui fait un
travail remarquable au quotidien
également à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent à combattre ces prédateurs
qui peuvent de près ou de loin de vous
soigner et il a dit derrière cette rage
qui s'empare de moi m'incite aujourd'hui
plus que jamais à continuer le combat
dans celui de protéger d'accompagner au
mieux nos enfants nous devons rester
tous unis et surtout être ensemble y
compris sur les réseaux qui peuvent
devenir des fléaux des fléau dévastateur
yens une rumeur donc il a dit qu'il
voulait arrêter
leo matiz est ce que nous avons entendu
cette affaire c'est clément garenq et un
un garçon qui a toujours de très très
bonnes infos qui dit en interne on
m'indique que reichmann est en furie
depuis hier et qu'il remet en question
la reconduction de la série léo mattei
en raison de ce scandale
est-ce que vous avez des infos là dessus
gilles verdez est vraiment question
beaucoup de choses il est dévasté
totalement depuis hier alors la première
réaction à la production à la chaîne ça
a été la panique panique parce que
comment vont réagir les femmes
responsables des achats qui regardent
l'émission et lui jean-luc reichmann a
pris ça sur un plan personnel il faut
savoir que les grands gagnants comme
quesada ils sont gérés directement par
lui
ils ont des liens très étroits donc il
sait sans ça on peut pas lui reprocher
ce n'est aucunement reproche de matane
il s'est senti trahi parce que lui
peut-être benjamin vous avez des infos
peut-être que d'autres savaient lui ne
savait rien du tout non ça je ne sais
rien il s'est senti trahi
et depuis hier vous avez vu que son
communiqué quand même très prudent il ne
cite pas la faire en raison de la
présomption d'innocence cci les il est
dévasté
effectivement il remet en question
beaucoup de choses je ne sais pas
franchement il ya beaucoup d'incertitude
sur son avenir
oui tu as des infos s'il vous plaît
oui en plus maintenant ça ne fait que
commencer parce qu'en fait ça fait un an
que la cybercriminalité sur lui le fils
dépôt de plainte de la jeune fille 2010
ea a compliqué leur tâche c'est que
quand il est souvent en voyage et que
quand il est là il vit les volets clos
les fêtes tout fermer complètement du
monde et de sa famille et donc ça a
compliqué la tâche cessé que lundi la
nuit qui s'ennuie mais si ça se trouve
il est chez lui et qui sont intervenus
ils ont pris tellement d'ordinateurs il
commence à peine à analyser le contenu
du disque dur
d'accord ils ont tombé de l'argent
liquide chez lui pas qu'on se dit il ya
diffusion d'image pornographique et il
n'y a rien derrière
alors là compliqué la question qu'on se
pose aussi tf1 et endemol était-il au
courant donc l'autre producteurs et la
chaîne est ce qu'ils étaient au courant
vous nous dites non vous êtes sûr sûr
sûr et certain mathieu sûr et certain
moi j'avais tf1 j'ai aussi des gens
n'aiment damon qui m'ont dit c'est
impossible impossible de savoir d'abord
sur les sur les casiers judiciaires on
peut vérifier qu'une seule partie moi
même je vais annoncer qu'il avait été
condamné et par ailleurs il le dit
franchement aussi chaîne des vols oui
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas vérifier tout
le monde
l'émission est diffusée 365 jours sur
365 avec trop quatre candidats c'est
plus de 1000 candidats donc on ne peut
pas dire est que tout le monde ce qui
est sûr c'est que tf1 pourrait
éventuellement attaquer endemol pour
avoir abîmé son image et éventuellement
mais tf1 n'est aucunement juridiquement
touchés de près ou de loin
de loin il achète une émission à une
démone avec un casting ou alors que risc
christian quesada aujourd'hui c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose selon
les informations de rtl
donc question quesada dort en prison ce
soir sur les plateaux télé beaucoup se
posent la question de ce que risque
christian qui étaient là s'il est
condamné
alors est-ce que vous avez des réponses
à nous donner ici autour de la table je
crois que gilles bien sûr aller réponse
vous avez enquêté gilles et vous pouvez
répondre à nos téléspectateurs ce soir
iris très précisément sept ans de prison
et 100 mille euros damende dans un autre
volet pour détention et peut-être
diffusion d'imagés pédopornographiques
et il est aussi poursuivi pour tentative
de corruption de mineur c'est 50-50
présent et cent mille euros d'amendé
effectivement 5 c'est que commencer s'il
dort en prison c'est parce que le juge a
considéré que comme il y avait déjà eu
des condamnations
il ya un risque de réitération et le mot
est très fort serre qu'il a considéré
que le laisser en liberté
présenter un danger mais pour des jeunes
donc ça veut dire franchement on ne
préjuge pas de l'issue judiciaire encore
une fois présomption d'innocence mais le
dossier est lourd
cirilli à se poser qui est très
importante c'est que si l' affaire était
sorti
présomption d'innocence et on en parle
la seule question qu'il faut se poser
c'est que l'affairé sortie et ce soir on
a appris sur rtl qu'il avait déjà été
condamné en 2000 et c'est ça ce qui est
plus grave pour moi aujourd'hui très
grave tout est grave mais c'est de
savoir qu'en fait on a mis à l'antenne
pendant le temps tentant de mois et
d'années quelqu'un qui avait déjà été
condamné donc j'imagine et des
magistrats qui a regardé la télé la
police parfois il ya des gens qui
regardaient la télé et qui savaient
qu'ils avaient été condamnés qui ne
pouvait rien dire
qu'est ce qu'on vient vous dès
maintenant c'est pour ça que je pense
que honey honnêtement ça me paraît
difficile que personne n'avait qu'à pas
c'est pareil les appeler qui que ce soit
honnêtement après le gérer c'est une
tanaka machine sera compliqué à tuer
mais on est fiers qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fait s'il avait senti ça avant lille t
on
il a été alors voilà donc je voulais dis
donc donc en fait gilles et douches pour
iris qu'en fait 12 on n'en sait sa
vaisselle ont fait en excluant 1000
euros damende absolument septembre
prison mais ça dépend c'est dommage
parce que parmi les images des images de
viols aggravés sur des enfants 2,50 donc
il ya des graduations aussi dans tous
les cas aucun cas une enquête est
ouverte en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce soit il est en prison et services
à jour arrive en gare de melun
il avait présenté il ya deux ans mais
voilà après il a tout avoué exactement
voulais rajouter ce que qu'il ya des
infos ceux qui ont des infos de parler
mais moi y'a un truc qui me frappait qui
m'avait frappé à l'époque de star
académie qui me frappe aussi pour la
télé réalité c'est que les analyses
psychologiques ne sont pas si poussée et
quand vous mettez dedans mais là c'est
un autre sujet vous saurez vous pouvez
un autre débat moi je sais qu'un jour
n'importe quoi raconte sa vie qu'ils
avaient faim car en effet d'être sorti
en livre de poche habituellement une
trentaine d'exemplaires en 15 jours il
va retirer de france aujourd'hui